I've been trying to explain what it's
like to be directed by your co-star
Bradley did the most extraordinary thing
but I'm still trying to get my head
around it was sort of like a Jedi Mind
thing but that that he would be able to
as Lenny elicit the response he wanted
in Me by adjusting his performance and
you know very rarely was he giving me
verbal notes they were always in
character but that so often in his
performance he would alter how
ultimately I would respond that's your
dream as a filmmaker to be able to dream
cinematically as big as you can for
story and then have actors be able to
fulfill that that's you know that's what
you pray for